If the transformation matrix T is equal to
three zero zero three, choose
which sketch can represent
this transformation when applied
to the red quadrilateral.
This is fascinating!
They don't give us any coordinates,
save for the vertices of
the quadrilateral, which are
really the most useful points
to use when thinking about
potential transformations.
So let's just make up some
just to see what would happen
to the particular coordinates
that we're looking at.
And I think that will give us enough
information to think about this.
I encourage you to do
it on your own first.
Pause the video.
Come up with some coordinates
for this red quadrilateral.
Then, see what transformation
you get and which of these
seem to be closest to
the one that you got.
I'm assuming you've had a go at it.
Let's just say for the sake of argument
that this point right over here.
That right there, you could
say that's the position vector.
I'll represent it as a column vector.
Let's say this is a square.
So this is one comma one.
I'll just write that as
a column vector one one.
And let's say this one then
would be one negative one.
One negative one.
Then, this one over here
could be represented
by the position vector
negative one negative one.
Negative one negative one.
Finally, this point
right over here could be
represented by the position
vector negative one one.
Negative one one.
So let's see what the
transformation matrix would do
when it transforms these four points.
The way I'm gonna think about it,
let me just take our
transformation matrix.
So, three zero zero three.
And I'm gonna multiply it
by a two by four matrix
that represents all of
these position vectors.
I'm gonna multiply it by,
we have this point one one.
That's our first point.
We have the point one negative one.
One negative one.
We have this point which
is negative one one.
Negative one one.
And then we have this point
which negative one negative one.
Negative one negative one.
These were convenient points to pick since
they didn't give us the points because
it'll make the math
fairly straightforward.
What is this going to be equal to?
We have a two by two.
Two by two.
Times a two by four.
Matrix multiplication is defined here
cause we have the same number of columns
as we have rows, right over here.
This is going to result
in a two by four matrix.
This is going to give us
another two by four matrix,
which makes sense, cause
we're going to need four
column vectors here for our
four new transformed points.
Let's figure out what it is.
The first column vector, right over here.
We can think about this
row and this column.
Or actually, the first
position right over here
the first row, first entry
is this row, this column.
The second one's going to be
the second row and the first column.
So let's see, three times
one plus zero times one.
Well that's three plus zero
so this is going to be three.
Then over here, zero times
one plus three times one
is going to give us three as well.
I think you see already a pattern here.
To get the the x-coordinate for each
of these vectors, we're
involving this row.
And this row, we really just multiplied
the three times the x-coordinate here
and then we don't involve the y-coordinate
because we're multiplying it times zero.
We'll see that over and over again.
So over here you have three times one.
Three times one plus
zero times negative one.
So it's just really three
times one, which is three.
Then over here you see
this for the y-coordinate
each time we're only
involving the y-coordinate
of the point before transformation.
You see zero times one is zero.
So we're essentially not
thinking about the x-coordinate.
And then it's just three times
negative one, which is negative three.
You see what its doing, it's just scaling
each of these up by a factor of three.
Three times negative one is negative three
plus zero times one,
so it's negative three.
Then, it's going to be
zero times negative one
is zero plus three times one is three
and then finally, three
times negative one.
Three times negative one plus
zero times negative one is negative three.
And zero times negative one plus
three times negative one
is negative three again.
So what's going to happen to it?
Well, each of these
coordinates essentially
get pushed out by a factor of three.
Actually this one seems to be the closest
to the one we're thinking about.
How do I know that?
Well look at this.
This is the point one
comma one right over there.
One comma one.
It gets mapped to the
point three comma three.
So, one two three.
One two three.
This is three comma
three right over there.
This got mapped to that and
we see it with each of them.
One negative one.
One negative one gets mapped
to three negative three.
Then, we have negative one one.
Negative one one.
Negative one one is getting
mapped to negative three three.
Finally, of course,
negative one negative one.
Negative one negative one gets mapped
to negative three negative three.
It's definitely the second.
The second diagram is the one that
represents the transformation matrix T
being applied to the red quadrilateral.